but the point is we we have more power
yes we have we so so if we are going to
get more power it comes with
responsibility having more of the
responsibility because the men the men
have one choice condom or no condom we
can we can we know when we're ovulating
you know when you're you should who gets
who gets to choose whether or not
they're on birth control men or women
the plan B men or women women who gets
to choose when if if you have sex on or
off your when you're ovulating men or
women who has the choice to track their
cycle men or women women who has the
choice to get an abortion women women
okay so that's that's the point